[Music]
and for the experience news I did it for
the experience and experience points
please submit a buy back I did not I did
not did not are you holding that we all
got a hold something cuz we're all
nervous you guys could just relax it
okay alright okay
whoa don't tell me to relax all right
Studio Ghibli is so committed to the
theatrical experience as no plans to
ever stream their films give me some
context on dvd/vhs interested yes yes
VHS I mean like maybe they might have
that mean cuz Ghibli's kind of all right
there from like what the 90s 80s right
yeah that would still have I don't think
they're gonna do it anymore and because
I know they're no more prints no more
yeah gee kids who owns the North
American distribution rights of all
Studio Ghibli movies oh my god I've said
they're never gonna put it online
Netflix and any other like streaming
services because they want to prioritize
the theater experience right they wanna
like know they're coming like
everybody's hint entering digital age
where like you know everybody I can see
that yeah I'll tell you what they just
did a release for the matrix and I'll
tell you that it is an entirely
different experience if you yeah I know
the first time I actually watch The
Matrix was owned on HBO TV I have to
agree those like watching something in
the theater is way different than
watching it like just like on demand on
a streaming service or maybe even on a
DVD like having going to the theater
there's something about the theater
growing experience that I really enjoy
well you like the crowd experience right
yeah I like being I hate the crowd
expense on the crowd though like
theaters if you're going to Arclight
like that's that's an enjoyable crowd
where everybody is there to appreciate
it and there is if you're going to like
a $2 movie theater no that's that's the
worst I don't know about that well
because I saw in game like three times
when it came out first I saw an eye pick
because I didn't want like the crowd to
like like wouldn't they react too much
you know and you're just missing line
yeah
yeah so and then I saw it again with you
guys and the AMT I'll hammer that she
was [ __ ] annoying because I got we had
the cue ball on our right they were like
[ __ ] drunk we got people ya keep
leaving in front of us and everything is
just yeah it's just totally different
yeah see I I have to agree with I I love
like getting immersed in movies and like
watching them for what they are and
everything like that and then for me
sound is just like it's super intense
fair so when I'm like watching a movie
and all of a sudden like I have like a
baby crying in the back corner or like
this popcorn just being like chewed like
mouth wide open and I'm just like oh I
can't enjoy the movie at that point yeah
I think for me it's like everybody's
partaking that experience together like
don't get me wrong I still I'm down to
like watch a movie in the theater that's
like just empty right there's something
about that but it's also like I enjoy
being part of that community and that
experience together where everybody is
like reacting to the state to the same
thing like there's a suspenseful moment
everybody is predicting them that I'll
give you this opening nights movie movie
opening nights I think are something
that like you can still go and enjoy and
and enjoy that crowd experience yes
because I remember I did that for
Avengers and that was fun mhm but I just
did it for Joker and that was like it
came out like a week or two after or I
saw it a week or two after kind of film
that you can and that's not the kind of
film that you can like have big
reactions because it's all supposed to
be suspense totally that's tense it's
like I was anxious like the entire time
and that was so is it particularly for
you like opening nights like for certain
types of films yeah it depends on the
movies like I think if you're going that
route yeah I need appends it like
adventures the fun movie yeah exactly
like Star Wars I'm gonna go in cheering
whenever I see lightsabers pop out you
know but if I'm okay if I'm going to
want to talk Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood I might everybody shut up
that's yeah that's a good point too it
depends on the type of movie that you're
watching like a quiet place there's
something you want to see in theaters
yeah see
see that's then that's where III quite
place now yeah I might I might value on
that one because again it's all about
like you know it's suppose that you're
supposed to be immersed and like that's
all about the sound and everything at
that but if you got like somebody that's
like walking up oh yeah but there's no
way I would watch quiet place on the
laptop because I did it I was like oh
yeah if you're like a home theater
system or like you know you put on some
really good headphones or something like
that then I would say dude I want to go
for that the home theater thing so do
you think that the G bleee you know
production company would be okay if
let's say hypothetically in 20 years
everybody has like a really nice home
theater system with like complete parity
with movie theaters do you think okay
that's cool we'll start streaming now no
point if you have that system you would
have a DVD blu-ray yeah you have you
have a collection like you wouldn't so
actually the only way you get is home
video outside of the at Racal see her
just hold home videos that they had so
there's only Home Videos I don't know
that the home video would mean VHS
though I know so as anything in the past
but they're not releasing anything else
in future so I don't think your cave
also include like blu-rays yeah yeah
because it's a video for home see but
then we're they don't think VHS though
yeah exactly but then you're like moving
away from like a digital era like the
digital air that we're in because
they're trying to like still cohesively
met meshed together like the streaming
services and the theater experience but
then if everyone has a home theater and
their system in there in there like
units or their house or whatever then
it's like well now we're killing off the
theater experience like out of like
going to the movies and that's gonna
like cause a big shift so that's all for
me I I can appreciate them I respect
them for the decision that they make
because as much as I would like their
films to be strange because I do enjoy
listening to them in the background I do
understand the point that they're
getting at is that they want people to
just have like their undivided attention
to their movies because the movies are
magical like I really do enjoy them my
favorite one is Princess Mononoke by the
way so far yeah you said that clever you
watch that like a year ago and it was
back out
I was like good how do you say sorry
it's cool but that's cheating about G
kit so that's their their selling points
every year they're gonna have a studio
ghibli festival so for like the holiday
season so like in October you gotta
watch period away in November you get my
princess mononoke is being released
that's it events so certain theaters
throughout the nation every every year
decays plans to release the classics so
that people can come together in a
theater I like that appearance it again
so that that is their plan every year to
have the festival because it's still
kind of like on like not necessarily on
demand but it's more frequent than like
one theater screening at the premiere
and then it never comes back right so I
bear that weight sensor that the home
theater thing they don't these from
their quotes it seems like they're
against the home theater they want
people to collectively come to a theater
every year and enjoy to celebrate it
together you know what I think that's
like really keeping the theater
experience together is the cult movies
you see like the Rocky Horror Picture
Show every Halloween every Halloween and
then they also have like the live
performances that go along with those
films have you guys been to it I've been
by that I didn't go to it because those
people look weird I love it it's so it's
super fun like everybody dresses like
they have like a male's only night where
like guys dress and drag and like they
play the female roles and like it's it's
a fun experience I've been twice no once
okay Joseph as a guy and go yeah
identify as a guy and you can go oh yeah
you just dress as you are identify as a
guy and go yeah there you go
there you go what I just identify as a
female but then dress as a guy and just
go I'm like oh my god it really is us
man
try to figure out a loophole in this but
I like what I'm talking about loopholes
Julia doesn't last week so what that's
right you can't talk about whatever you
want here which by the way I am going to
the Ghibli Museum in Japan like Miyazaki
like exists it's really cool because
then they have all the display of like
the things that I mean you get to see
some animations and like paper and then
I was gonna say earlier I'm gonna catch
a lot of flack but I haven't actually
seen any of not on the 5 line your name
oh no no it's not because I have been
like against them it's just that I've
never been introduced to them you need
better friends bro I don't have friends
dude they fell you yeah I think we are
her fencing we fell yeah spirit away
tonight like I'm down to watch them I
just never got around to their [ __ ]
people
no guys no we can't allow him to watch
it here at the Washington theatres with
all bad though yes it is some holiday
seasons you know I enjoyed that too your
experience so it all go we should go but
that's what I'm saying it's like it's
like everybody that would go are diehard
fans or people that have never seen it
before and the diehard fans would go and
then they would dress up and like you
know and as I'm saying like the cult
movies the cult followings like people
who dress up and go these theaters and
like have an appreciation for it and
have a big appreciation for me as our
[ __ ] following oh yeah oh yeah
massive so I think yeah they'll have a
lot of cosplayers oh you can take me to
one of those bro if we dress out I'm
dressing up with you
so I don't know spirited away as the end
of this month Mononoke ascended next
month
oh and then we have the tale of Princess
Kaguya we see now that's new I haven't
seen that I haven't seen that one either
but here's here's my question now is as
a newbie never seeing these movies as
Shawna's do you go to these like
experience of a theater yeah that's true
setting or shoot by yourself first and
then go for the experience because I
think there's some give and take with
you have dethrown yes but what's a
better experience do you go I feel like
Sean likes the car first the first
experience see you could do either one
you could watch it by yourself and get
that experience and then go and like
experiences the larger thing and it just
isolate elevate if it was like Star Wars
coming out and I was like Brewer like
you never seen Star Wars before wait
until they do a tree release cuz that's
a whole different course than watching
you by yourself but I'm not knocking on
that either of them I'm saying like or
you can go in the first time experience
like me and you drive you guys drag me
to the theater and it's all like the
die-hard fans who are all dressed up and
like like that first experience that
first taste of these films and it's like
this huge experience like depends on
what you would want to do but I wouldn't
be opposed to either of them either you
start here and then it escalates into
the big event or you start with the big
event and then just continue on from
there say I think be choice right in the
sense it-it's like you know if you go to
a Star Wars film it's like you can do
the whole you know get immersed into a
dress up cheer things like that but then
it's like if you go to something that's
tame or that you know you want to like
meet prospective and dedicate your whole
yeah you're a whole like attention to it
you don't want all this like crowded
environment well now think about it I
thought one of the Kill Bill of it
releases and they were actually they
weren't very like well maybe cuz you
know yeah like you know you don't get a
lot hoopla on that but you would if you
would like they do like an Avengers
really something you would get a lot of
hoopla
[Music]